pedro gonzalez is associated at
chronicles he joins us tonight pedro
this seems like kind of a sea change you
didn't used to be allowed to say i hate
an entire race of people and hope for
their extinction wired magazine wouldn't
kind of have your back on that but now
they do what is this right well it's a
new phenomenon that goes just beyond
books but i think it's important to
actually do an overview of the last
white man basically the characters
suffer through these apocalyptic changes
as violence escalates as whites
disappear
pale-skinned militants in woodland camo
stalk the streets attacking people with
impunity from the cops but a calm
settles upon the world once whites
disappear from its face forever
a book like this which is somewhere
between
racial exterminationist literature with
a kind of wistful touch and liberal
pornography could only be written about
one group and that privilege is reserved
for whites there's a whole industry for
this stuff tucker
and there are no shortage of eager
consumers who who eat this stuff up
because they believe truly that there's
no limit to the amount of demeaning that
we can inflict on whites and again
it goes beyond bad books like the last
white bit i'll give you a different but
related example of this phenomenon the
minneapolis public schools and local
teachers union have recently instituted
a new policy in which when it comes to
downsizing and layoffs
the rule is white teachers must be laid
off before any teacher of color in other
words they've codified racial
discrimination against whites in real
life not in fiction
in an age we talk a whole lot about
discrimination and hate speech we've
actually formally instituted it in the
in the united states against the group
who we blame for this stuff and that is
obviously white people
yeah it can't i mean it's you know
racism doesn't ever end well and at this
scale it'll end very badly and i hope
they stop it immediately it's it's it's
beyond belief patrick gonzalez i
appreciate the clarity of that thank you
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight